so
hello
we are live gentlemen welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and this quite dark and
miserable autumnal Sunday how are you
gentlemen
doing well
doing well doing well let's get into it
[Music]
I don't know why I said let's get into
it such a strange
anyway dude you're hyped hyped for for
uh ask me anything I'm hyped come on
guys today on the live you can jump in
and discuss and ask us any questions you
can direct the conversation if you want
in a little while
um after we've discussed black panther
for five or ten minutes and if at any
point I go yes or do it United a plane
so
um it and it's still nil nil so I'm
stressing but anyway
we're not here to talk about Manchester
United however much we should let's talk
about Manchester United
uh Harris your feelings are excited
talking to the Brits yeah yeah damn
right oops oops football team do you
support uh Matt just out of Interest
I've never asked you I don't
need it I do not like football I'm
Bloody Mary okay bloody nude
[Laughter]
it's not a game
hi Shelly hey Dave hey Bob oh Bob's got
a question over crossover franchise
Jurassic Max with survivors he does this
every damn week and it always takes
we're live Bob I have to read this and
try to understand what you're saying
that he's saying Jurassic Park and Mad
Max put together
mind is just beautiful isn't it but um
it'll work I like that it has to be fun
it's better fast and furious in Jurassic
Park franchise
yeah his profile picture is cool but
anyway so
before we get into whatever the audience
want to talk about
um I did want to talk about Black
Panther I saw it last night
I know Matt you haven't seen it but I'm
going to describe a few elements to you
and you can tell me whether you think it
sounds brilliant or stupid but first of
all before we get into that Harris what
what did you think of the movie because
I know you've seen it
I so I guess we're going spoilers here
no should I go into specifications
but try to be a little bit careful don't
don't go too crazy okay I I'll just
generalize it uh I liked it typically uh
not a not a whole whole lot but I liked
it I feel like on a general level but
there were some certain things like iron
heart and I love I love Martin Freeman
but Everett Ross didn't need to be in
this movie and those two arcs in general
cut that and I would have liked the
movie a lot more
Russ is one of the few things in the
movie I liked I I liked everything he
did but it just wasn't necessary
yeah yeah that's kind of weird because
yeah he's basically because he is
hail sir
um
yeah so we'll talk about ironheart
really quickly because she appears in
the comics
um a lot and we know that we're getting
an iron Heart TV series
basically this character was shoehorned
into the movie because we're getting a
TV series
and that was the only reason and her
suit looks stupid
um it's just it's really bad not as bad
as
um akoy's I think I'm saying that name
I'll call you
um her suit later on in the movie when
she does the what was it called Midnight
something uh the Midnight Angel Midnight
Angel
really bad
um so but I'm going to argue now now a
lot of people are going to watch Black
Panther and they're going to go with
work and I don't I don't like you know I
don't like the term work
but even if this film does do some
signal that you know virtue signaling
and whatever else I don't really care
because the story is not good
um and that's the main problem the story
is there at best
and and the big thing is uh what's the
difference between a good film and a
great film normally like this sort of
thing you know like a Marvel superhero
movie or something like that
any ideas
okay say that one more time what's the
difference between a good movie and a
great movie I've said it before on the
channel
it's the villain if if you've got a
great villain if you've got a good
villain that always elevates elevates
the movie a little bit the villain in
this movie is the most forgettable
weird little freak that it's it's just
it's it's just borderline stupid but
this would you not I've not seen the
film be scared of a human being coming
at you if he had tiny little wings on
his feet they may let him fly or would
you just go what the [ __ ] is that
and laugh at him what like Apollo yeah
it's like um
Hermes no definitely not
it's stupid
I I liked parts of that just because he
was able to I mean the flying looked
silly but the concepts of it I guess I
you know I go I go sci-fi real quick
I would try and steal his boots
and calls me
wings
I'll try and Chuckles
that part's cool I thought just because
that like officially officially I guess
I still haven't seen uh Miss Marvel but
I know she's technically a mutant but
that was like officially like for our
general audiences mutant in there it's
that [ __ ] took out like a store thumb
as well
everybody listen
I'm a mutant there we go I said it and
and then the card moved up I mean it is
that blatant in it it's just like
we could have gotten it from the feet
the wing the winged feet
yeah it's it's completely like
movie movie I'm a muted
it's just so random
um but honestly the winged feet so
they've done the winged feet to go
that's why he flies and I'm just there
thinking that wouldn't work he wouldn't
be able to fly with those he'd go it
would make a noise and occasionally it
or maybe he might be able to jump a
little higher but those timers so just
make him fly
don't put [ __ ] I don't know if it was
something in the comic or yeah that's
been in the comic since the 1930s so
that's that's got a long long history
there I'll leave out just I mean Marvel
I've been really good at that in the
past that they sort of like play up to
the comics but like leave out the stuff
that's stupid
and and they just go up to silly but
don't cross the line
what did you say about throw 11 Thunder
recently
they're dancing all over the bloody line
let's go
screw the line let's run over and see
how far we can get before people really
get angry at us and it's like I'm
starting to get really pissed off for
Marvel
I just think
there's some of my favorite movies the
last 10 years and now there's like it's
four for four for me they're just crap
they can't reach the peak but this was
at least better than a lot of the other
recent ones in a term of like tone
because they actually kept themselves
self-serious the entire film instead of
making fun of the place that they're in
uh so that was nicer but it just it it's
it wasn't that return to that gold
standard that we were looking for
it's yeah I was really hopeful there's
some very cool scenes in this movie yeah
and some of the visuals are stunning
some of the special effects though are
again really dodgy
um where he's flying what is called the
Nama is uh no more is flying
and not good
and this is their facts better than iron
hearts
that was just rubbish they're an element
to this film you just think why did they
do that it's just like just leave it
just make the film half an hour shorter
just just don't do it
um and but also the villains the whole
villain thing these these blue dudes
they're not scary all the way you're
just thinking
the Avatar ones are better
or you know it's just like they're just
they're just not good I mean um they
they're fighting on the bridge
I was genuinely worried that okoya was
gonna die yeah because I really like the
character but
um and then she just doesn't and then
she gets a stupid suit I'm just like
harsh just a terrible movie
um my sons loved it I could say what you
think of film guys and they go oh yeah
it's great and I was like you're wrong
you're both wrong and here's why and
then just stood there for 20 minutes
explaining it
yeah the the tower can like Atlantis
esque stuff is definitely the best but
it just doesn't
grab you like you want like like black
panther did so well originally I know
it's not everybody's favorite but it did
so well because it grabbed everybody but
it grabbed a culture particularly where
they try to do the same thing with
telecon and neymore and all of that and
and who who's that speaking to because I
it just I don't know it was it was good
but it just didn't go benevolent needed
to yeah well I was waiting for them to
go oh Atlantis at some point and they
didn't they never mentioned at least
they had enough sense not to do that but
legal issues
possibly nobody owns the rights to
Atlantis do they uh Warner Brothers in
DC because they put Aquaman out first
you just can't oh that was the other
reference it but it would be confusing
at the same time well that was the other
thing wasn't it at this film at times
felt like Aquaman but I I think they did
a slightly better job than Aquaman the
the thing at the end of Aquaman is awful
that's that's a good comparison though
just because
they're they're both kind of middling
you both expect you expect more from
both of them
hmm
I don't know what's the better film at
the end of the day I want to say black
panther but
I had a lot more fun in Aquaman and
that's not necessarily like the gauge
I'm looking for for a good film but
this is the five cage it should be
entertained by a movie
um I I don't really care if a film is
woke or silly or think if I'm
entertained by it and you know I have
quite a serious job when I'm not doing
this and then you know when you watch a
film I want to just tip brain off
popcorn and you know
this I feel like we were primed for like
we knew this film was gonna be like
about grief and stuff so like people
people are going in there like
mentally preparing for something like
that and it's it's just it skims the
surface I feel like
we we barely talked about
t'challa's passing I mean it was that
should have been a much more Central
focus of the film and it's it wasn't not
but it was more very surface level keep
moving instead of actually dealing with
what the ramifications of not having to
Chala are anymore yes we got that
personally from shuri a little bit and
from uh oh my God what's the Queen's
name Angela Bassett
umanda Rwanda Queen raimondo and we we
get some of that but it's just
it's it's good for those character beats
and a little bit of Nakia but
it's such it's such a large world and
now that wakanda itself is being
attacked by another large underwater
world and it's still a part of the wide
world itself and it's engulfing all
these different little triangles within
the plot
and it just doesn't hit that beat that
you want to do I don't care about that
either you know they've left it on this
Cliffhanger with obviously that this is
going to be the the plot of the next
movie whatever and I'm just coming away
from going I don't care in the slightest
I mean I I do love Martin Freeman but
Everett Ross and Contessa de LaFontaine
were only literally they were in here to
set up something else and
I like that in the MCU but it has to be
done naturally and fluidly and this
wasn't not natural because it did fit to
a degree
but it just it was jarring for what the
actual story itself was it I feel like
this would have been better
self-contained because if wakanda had
help if if they were in talks with
Everett Ross why didn't Everett Ross say
hey CIA or hey Shield Sword whatever it
may be we need some help right now
there's some crazy things going on
what's happened to shield and sword
we saw him in space
now the director of Shield yeah and
we've just not seen it since
that's like four or five movies now it's
not been mentioned
I know it's coming into the thingy Wars
that we're coming into but it's just not
been mentioned but anyway we can talk
about something else because I think
Matt might fall asleep
um
I was trying to find you a decent Inn to
talk about other Marvel films that have
been good this year
because I don't think I think there's
only been one there's only been one that
I was genuinely excited for and I
actually enjoyed and that was Spiderman
it's not really a Marvel movie but yes
it was very very good how's it not
Marvel
really
is horrible
no because it's filmed at um uh Sony
Studios isn't it as well
um
it was it it's it's that the entire
point of the film I think is the company
it's the combination yeah yeah
in association with Marvel is it but yes
it is sad though that the only way
Marvel can make a good movie is with
Sony
um saying that
uh but then Sony tries to make their own
and then they're twice as bad well Venom
Carnage was Bloody awful
morbius
a morbius was Bloody you know both those
movies the problem is they're
um
Sony Marvel Sony's not Sony yeah the
Marvel and fox are the same company now
Panther but um yeah Sony still very much
on its own still one of the largest um
companies on the planet Zone
um
Sony make Doctor Who
yes they do they own thingy
um they also they bought MGM Studios at
um I think it was called Silver
something or something like that Studios
but um Central City they bought Century
cities in the
um so that's now so many pictures
um but anyway
um
what's my train of thought I was gonna
say something else uh no um yeah so
something so Sony makes Venom which is
bloody awful and you know my main
problem with Carnage is if the editing
is really bad and more Beast is the same
it's there's no rhythm to it but then
they can make Spider-Man it was
brilliant because I think that's the
best Superior movie we've seen in years
I thought it was great
yeah and I I just I can't do Venom I I
think they did really really well with
Venom and Tom Hardy and then they threw
everything else out the entire story
narrative plot they were like yeah we
don't need that we got Tom Hardy and
Venom and we're good
yeah and to a degree they are but I just
I need an actual good story and neither
one of those have been good stories I
know people like them in like a popcorn
turn the brain off but
and Venom's a little more cool than that
Venom needs some heart to him
it just I think judiconna's got a good
point to it that it does actually seem
it isn't it pretty much dead on when
Stan Lee died they've done nothing
decent since
I think this week was the three or four
years anniversary of his passing
something like that didn't he die just
after Ragnarok
that sounds right
um
for sure
yeah it was before in game um I know the
last one he appeared in no actually the
last one appeared in was Marvel wasn't
it Miss Marvel
um uh Captain Marvel wasn't his last
um but yeah and actually I really like
Captain Marvel I know a lot of people
I actually woke at that but I I just
thought it was a really good film
um I don't like her
um every time I watch her in an
interview you can see with the rest of
the Marvel cast and you can see that
they hate it they're just
hoping she didn't say something oh God
uh but guys in in the comments if you
want um anything do you want us to talk
about or any questions you've got first
release throw in but I do have a
do it I do have an interesting point
here that
they were talking about obviously
because Bob here has got the image from
and the data Stood Still one of the
greatest Sci-Fi movies ever ever made
for me the original what did you think
of the Keanu Reeves version
I really liked it
only because I never like I'd never seen
the original so when I watched it when
did it come out like what to a 2000 five
six and like that's a long time ago
anyway 15 15 years ago so yeah yeah I
went to cinema to watch it I don't know
who I went with or why I went like I
didn't have any interest but I actually
I went I come out of it like enjoy and
having enjoyed myself
have you ever actually seen the Cavalry
station Harris
I have not
I've seen the original version but I
haven't seen the Keanu I mean
the original those the special effects
were done on no budget because people
didn't want Sci-Fi movies back then they
didn't know it was a b movie it was the
film you went to watch before the proper
film was on
um but there was like if just just
golden age or Cinema they just kept
making these great movies like them you
know with the giant ants
and they made this film and they made
you know there's a tarantula and all
these great B movies
um but but this was just it's it's
probably the I mean this this really was
the start of
um
UFO sightings and things as well it
really sparked like 10 years where just
everybody kept freaking out
um
it's you know it's just it's just such
but but the cameras version was such a
bad movie The only thing I liked about
it was it had this um the the weapon
that he had that was going to destroy
the planet was a nanite you know there's
the ton of robots and all these robots
did was take molecules apart and
replicate so it's like this cloud and it
was sweeping across everything it was
just taking everything apart and I just
remember at the time thinking that is a
wicked weapon that is just like that's
terrifying it just it just wipes away
everything as it goes along
other than that
terrible other than that but uh I have
watched it since I think it was on
I was on TV at some point recently so I
watched it
having having the memory of enjoying it
when I was younger and
I watched it and it kind of just ends
like there's no
in a lot of good good Sci-Fi movies you
have like a climactic ending and it was
very anti-climactic
so I don't know if my if my enjoyment if
it's just because I was younger it was
the first time I'd ever watched you know
maybe it was like one of my first like
proper Cinema experiences or something
but that makes that makes a difference
though didn't it really
I'll tell you what is a question for you
guys but we'll we'll get into Panther
pickles question in a second but
Harrison will have no clue do you know
Benjamin Cisco is Harris
I like the name
you need to watch we really do need to
watch Deep Space Nine it's one of the
great TV shows oh wait a second Premier
League notification
come on now come on come on United
uh anyway I'll have a look who scored in
a second
um
they've just released a comic book now
and at the end of D Space Nine Cisco
goes into the Wormhole and basically
becomes a God he joins there's these
gods in the Wormhole kind of and he he
goes to join them but now in the comic
he's come back and he's now back in the
world so will Benjamin Cisco be in Star
Trek Picard
Matt I think you you are Star Trek don't
you I watched that I I'm nowhere near
like knowing any of these characters I
think I'm only online I've done the
first season of TNG
so I just looked him up though I do
recognize him
like I've seen him I've seen him before
to answer the question Panther
um I hope not
um because I I really think writing him
back in to the series is going to be
complicated but
I suspect he will because that's why
they've just done the comic
and they did this last time for series
one and series two of Picard they
released this comic that sort of gave us
a load of backstory and then it went
into things so
probably but I don't know
guys so before we get into that let's
see who's scored Christian Erickson
um
first what what was your first then so
Matt do you think that was your first
sort of like sci-fi cinemary experience
yes yeah it definitely was it was
how about you Harris
I'm trying to think because I I feel
like I'd seen something
older maybe eclectic or something but I
mean it's most likely just Star Wars
because I I had almost every single Star
Wars growing up and I love that
are y'all getting reverberation for me
um
um for me it was Star Trek the
Undiscovered Country I skived off school
I was about 13 or 14 and I Skyped off
school and I sat in the cinema on like a
two o'clock
um on a weekday and there's like two
other people in there on their own as
well
um and I watched
Star Trek
um
it's still my favorite Star Trek movie
I think it does these films I think they
do have they do impact you know it's
funny at that certain age but sci-fi was
really big when I was sort of like in my
teens so I think that's why I still love
it so much
um I don't think it was really for you
but is it more fantasy for you guys or
let's play Star Wars
I'd probably say the fantasy era
probably was more when I was younger
um
little drawings come out the Harry
Potter series
like Twilight and all stuff like that
I think Harry Potter was the one that I
actually probably went to cinema to see
the rest of them I never really cared
that much about
but
I I I I always got my science fiction
fix from television
and and movies had already been out like
my dad got me into Star Wars
so I we had the videos VHS I'm that old
um
[Laughter]
I'm the best
I love the VHS you have to push it
and I remember the box of the VHS boxes
it's always like a vivid I've got um I
think I've got them in my
wardrobe now but um
the VHX box it had all three movies in
it and just a massive Darth Vader mask
and it looked amazing and they used to
be on the Shelf so we used to like to
take it down and then we'd watch it and
yeah it was um
that's where I got my sci-fi fix from
but in terms of Cinema
I I never really went to see movies like
growing up I still don't I don't really
go to the cinema I'll just wait until
it's on like Netflix or something
we'll get you there one day
we got you thank you yeah I mean with
the the the sequel series of Star Wars I
went to cinema to see every single one
of those okay because I never had that
experience of going to the cinema to see
Star Wars and I've I've said this to so
many people throughout the years I would
love to have been born in like the 70s
or
oh there's probably about 60s so I can
enjoy it go to see Star Wars for the
very first time
because that would have been amazing I
kind of had not quite the same but I
kind of had a little bit
um of a taste of that though because
before they did the not so good Trilogy
they released the digitally remastered
Star Wars and where they really souped
up the battle at the end and lots of
other things
like watching it for the first time it
was it was just at the cinema which
you'd not seen at the cinema in years
you know because I mean it hadn't been
honest enough for 20 years or something
but um that was and I remember that that
was it that was full Cinemas everybody
went to watch it
cues around the block like you know
um but I think that was start at the
beginning of like a bit of a Resurgence
of the cinemas though because I mean in
the 80s and 90s people didn't go
you know it's just like um Everybody
Wants it's a bit like what's happening
now with people watching streaming
movies at home everyone was watching vcr
and videos you know video night begins
alone and Schwarzenegger time
yeah but it was all nobody wanted the
cinema to watch him oh not as much
anyway but when it came out video
everyone was like yeah straight to
Blockbusters renting the movie you know
and um but it wasn't even Blockbusters
every every little town or whatever had
its own video shop and you know popcorn
just get a Chinese go home and your dad
mum and dad would probably go to the pub
and you know and that was your video
night sort of thing
um
yeah
there were some let's just talk classic
sci-fi movies that's the way the
evening's going I think everyone right
throw into the comments guys what's the
classics
um Close Encounters of the Third Kind is
when I fell in love with um is their
name has gone out my Pagan head
Spielberg sorry
Spielberg no no no no no the action
actor he's sending Jaws
uh
as soon as I see his name and then he
was in um another stake Act
and those films [ __ ] brilliant accent
I love him Richard Dreyfuss then I fell
in love with Richard Dreyfuss
um
and and I probably that's probably bled
into a lot of my um alien conspiracy
theories over the years as well
um I assume you've both seen it right
oh yeah
those encounters
damn it man right
it's probably how old is it
is a young man in it so 70
three
five you really think early 70s 77. okay
so 1977 game before I was born good year
um so just before Star Wars actually
something you said I would do in the
same year when it was just 77 or 78. uh
New Hope is 77 I think yeah yeah
um so same here so I mean there's a lot
of conspiracy theories actually that um
I wasn't alive
mentally since
I don't own a TV so much time I don't
have the internet I don't have a
computer I don't I don't know what I do
with my life
yep
um
by aliens there are a lot of conspiracy
theories around this and there's a lot
of conspiracy theories that like um a
lot of people in the media know
about the alien and this is Steven
Spielberg's way of trying to like let us
know and that a lot of sci-fi movies are
just trying to make it so that when you
see a UFO you don't get freaked out
um program in the nation just so when it
happens you're just like oh yeah yeah we
knew that was gonna happen
um I forget what it's called but there's
like operation somewhere other than it's
supposed to be called and it's they're
using the media to um downplay all these
things
funny mystery and UFO challenge talk
about it a lot
um
but whether it's true or not but I mean
it's such a great movie and so there's
actually though you look back at it when
I was a kid I remember watching it I
thought it was bornish crap I thought it
was so slow
but um watch it as an adult I can
appreciate it a little bit more but I
hated ET as well I thought ET was really
how do you hate YouTube really
it's too slow I loved E.T uh I used to
cry at that so good
yeah I can see you crying at that film
and if you want to get drunk that's
funny
um but other than that I just thought it
was a bit slow
um
can you think of any films like that
then like like for me E.T uh Close
Encounters the Third Kind thought they
were both born as crap I'm gonna freak
Harris out here when I was a kid
um I hated Star Wars
again I thought I thought it was boring
how is force and lightsabers boring what
kind of child were you James
it's too slow
I mean that there is it gotta be a bit
I'm talking when I was a kid when I was
10 and I was still running around
pretending to be a helicopter like ah
and my mom and dad made me watch it and
I just thought
boring
um
but as an adult I enjoy it have you got
any films like that anything as a kid
you thought were a bit dull but as an
adult you can now appreciate it now
they're thinking about the thing about
the classics I feel like there might be
some shows that were kind of like that
but I feel like with movies I always
thought oh that's weird but interesting
and then I kind of actually learned what
things typically were
um but I don't know I mean the only
thing I can think of something like that
would be the giver or something like
that where I just really I was forced to
to read it and watch it when I was
younger kind of deal and then you kind
of revisit it a little older and you're
like oh that actually is good not just
forced reading that's why they forced it
forced it on us you know at a young age
um I feel like Doctor Who is probably
probably mine when I was growing up
because it was like reruns and stuff on
TV all the time
and I didn't really like it I thought it
was a bit [ __ ] because it was like
horrible sets terrible acting
um it wasn't until the Revival
you know when it got good well for me I
know that's gonna like some people
really like the classic series
um
it wasn't until the 2005 Revival that
really made me as big of a fan of it as
I am now and I do appreciate the classic
series I have gone back and watched them
I appreciate them for what they are but
they're not what got me into it if you
know what I mean the the Revival started
with the ninth or tenth one right Dr
Wise yeah
okay
that was in 2005 and then 2006 David
Tennant took over yeah the David Tennant
is when it got good
um the Eccleston series was much better
than it than before but you could just
say they were doing it they were doing
it very quickly and then Eccleston
didn't really have his heart in it
um oh we definitely didn't you
definitely didn't yeah with tenant
onwards uh
to me it's got brilliant to men under
Matt Smith I thought it was just as good
um but I'm so excited for what they're
going to do with Doctor Who now with
David Tennant I'm I'm not I'm not sure
about this new doctor though
I've seen in a couple of things and I'm
I can't quite see how they're going to
do it but I think it's really good I
really like him in sex education
that's that guy in Cody or whatever his
name yeah yeah
sure to get one
it's spelled nqt but yeah it's YouTube
okay
I'm gonna have problems with that I keep
getting yelled at first saying names
wrong how hard would it be for you to go
on YouTube and just listen have people
say names that's literally what I did as
soon as he got announced I was like how
do you say
there was a YouTube video going shooting
I'm like okay now I know so I'm just
gonna I'm just going to say it right
from now on bothered I just think it's
funny but I still have everyone
I did a video where I particularly said
Scott Bakula's name wrong it's actually
Scott Bakula
um but I said his name wrong I said it
Bakula
um because
I I thought it was funny because I know
he famously said that it's like Dracula
so it's bacula Dracula I was about to
say how do you say the guy with the
fangs do you call him Dracula
of course in the Bram Stoker's movie a
few years ago another one with Keanu
Reeves in he says Dracula it's like
really in a really weird way so I
thought it would be funny to say Bakula
like he says Dracula but the problem was
I didn't say in the video that that's
what I was doing so I got a loads of
loads of comments going
nobody in on the joke I didn't I didn't
tell anyone
I just I just didn't mention it but then
I pinned a comment to the top saying
explaining my stupid joke that I didn't
put it and um and it's not funny after
if you have to explain is it the end of
the day
people don't read pin comments I've I've
I've I've tried to retroactively correct
something in a video and then they're
just like you still get comments about
it so it's like just just deal with it
if you make a mistake and they comment
it's an extra comment yeah I I just
pretend it hasn't happened now I
actually remember when I first started
doing this what I did I put a comment on
things saying in every single video I'm
going to do a deliberate mistake and
then whoever that was the first gets a
price is just a complete life because I
will make at least one mistake in every
single video
because it's quite hard doing this guys
talking now there's a there's a on on
Tech talk especially people do that
they'll they'll make a video and they'll
purposely mispronounce something because
they know people get into the comments
and on Tick Tock any kind of
engagement's going to make your video go
viral so if you
someone I know personally who does tick
tock done a video about pizza
but purposely said Pisa in the video
and everyone commented on it and that
video like went massive like three four
hundred thousand views just because she
said it wrong
I'm fine now I'm not going to worry
about it in the future speaking of which
if any of you have Tech talk at
Sidetrack we are actually on we are on
Star Trek we are on Star Trek we're on
tick tock
yeah
um why are we onto Tick Tock Matt
yeah but anything to try to push and
support the channel I'm all for so
absolutely brilliant but um I still
let's go I still don't know how it works
so
um
just to flip my earlier my question a
second ago on its head we have 22
followers as well we only started it
early yesterday didn't it was it
yesterday oh yesterday last night
I'll take 22 followers a couple of the
videos we've got like 15
000 1500 views or something but anyway
um I will do specific videos for it when
I have
I mean you absolute Legend as always God
I need to send her more presents which
is very very good Canadian what do you
send Canadians
syrup they got it I'm just trying to
think of the most stereotypical Canadian
thing possible
a big bale of hay
because they say hey sorry Sally's gonna
run away now she's an Alberta British
Columbia she might have some really good
burgers just send her a bunch of patties
you know sweet bait because the
carnivore at me not Canadian bacon
Canadian Bacon's crap any proper bacon
like maple bacon over there
I think of Bob is Megan a science
fiction or horror it's sci-fi horror
isn't it yeah
there you go good easy it's both
you can have cross genre movies all the
time you get sci-fi Horrors what's the
greatest sci-fi horror
the thing
we've had this conversation
we were talking earlier about
um about movies from your childhood
and I was thinking about something that
I I don't know if they count they must
count on the Sci-Fi actually but one
that I used to watch all the time
I absolutely loved I've not seen it for
probably like 10 years
I don't know if you've seen it's called
AI on intelligence the little yeah the
annoying little kid who was famous for
about five minutes in loads of films
that's Spielberg yeah the guy I think
he's the kid from
um
uh six cents
yes he is yeah yeah yeah
I absolutely love that film and there
was another one Bicentennial Man it was
a Robin Williams film ing is great that
was fantastic but no one ever talks
about it that's why
it was so good it lost you and me we're
the same
[ __ ] love it
it's very good you're a bit of it it's
you like rom-coms not by any chance I
love rom-coms I don't know why I'm
saying that like it's a bad thing all
right you put Sandra Bullock a Hugh
Grant in a movie and I am one happy
little camper not actually it's
fantastic
oh uh one of my favorite films of all
time is um two weeks notice the subject
I'll watch anytime I'm so happy
that was a good film yeah yeah well
remember one yeah oh dear
quickly that's rom-com you're your
favorite rom-com ever two weeks ago that
really I'm not the biggest fan but the
proposal is just too good for me I love
that one I'll tell you actually
Carrie Grant
um Father Goose
is the best rom-com ever made it's an
absolute classic and it's an absolute
classic there's never really been remade
um which is
unheard of you know you think so you're
calling for the Remake now
oh God probably please don't because it
needs to be carried around but if you
think think things like Serendipity
there that's actually a film that's just
been remade over and over again you know
it's like um uh I can't remember but
that was actually a classic
um a Cary Grant movie from back in the
day um was it indiscretion I forget but
um it's just the same film that's been
made over and over again
um
just I didn't press on it every time but
then you know the movie because they
always end up the Empire State Building
at the end
so they just do a slight Different Twist
on it
um Tom Hanks did one with um they're
growing
uh before we did You've got mail the
other one Sleepless in Seattle
um but yeah well if ever
Father Goose Carrie Grant it's an old
movie but you love it it's great yeah
Father Goose anything with Carrie
Grant's got to be good
he just did some brilliant he just did
some incredible films yeah and that's
like I don't watch a lot of old movies
but I'll watch a Cary Grant movie
anytime all modern one two weeks notice
how about you guys
for an old movie favorite it's rom-com
whatever or just rom-com
The Proposal I I just like the proposal
is my favorite it's not that old but
it's it's I just love that I'm not the
biggest rom-com guy but that one hits me
is Ryan Reynolds and Sandy Bullock and
Betty White oh Betty White's amazing
have you seen Silver they're like the
behind the scenes sort of like adverts
they did for it we're better
oh
hello
she's a national hero Ryan a national
hero
how about you Matt come on throw someone
uh I don't know I'm looking I'm looking
at a list of them to see if I recognize
anything
I mean Mr and Mrs Smith is an action
rom-com and I really like that film okay
because of a particular scene
yes I'll tell you what that whole movie
though is actually the opening sequence
where she's in that dress
um was was
interesting
um but yeah the fight scene when they're
about over there that was funny
was it just sort of right in the the end
it just sort of like the best bit of the
movie was like 30 minutes before the end
yeah
yeah Kelly's Heroes
that's a war movie surely
Jack
uh ball fella
um
completely bald he played Kojak and
come on somebody in the in the comments
help us out with this one
hey Siri who played Kojak
I've got a nose name as soon as it comes
up I'm gonna go oh Cool
Telly Savalas
you're two seconds too late so and you
spelled it wrong tell yourself Alice
um oh he came up just after
good Market the the comments actually
come come up a little bit late on on our
screen for some reason uh it's probably
like a five to ten second lag or
something yeah stupid YouTube can't do
anything like that that's because we're
doing it through stream now but anyway
yes thank you guys to Telly Savalas
absolutely brilliant brilliant in um
that shipper Poseidon Adventure as well
uh no not because I'm eventually the
second one he was in the second one
right we're really going off topic here
we know that we had a topic today
uh
oh yes that's a great sci-fi movie
Demolition Man you know we're talking
about different genre movies right so
you got like that that's a Sci-Fi Action
Movie
which you don't there aren't loads of
them
um
you know it's like
but that that's a good one and they are
there is talk about it coming back and
they want to talk about it maybe
becoming a series a streaming series
but um I think that was a couple of
years ago before
everything went sort of tishit
but um I would I would have watched that
it sounds fun
news stories
new Sci-Fi
yeah new Sci-Fi I I think there's room
for both
um and at Bob's Bob's gonna jump in on
this chat I'm sure I'm he's always said
um
whenever I talk about there being a
reboot if what about something new and
I'm completely on board with it
but you've got if I was an executive
producer though I'd be like I would be
tempted to go let's just reboot
something people or do you want to watch
rather than trying to get people to
watch something they don't know anything
about
and I'll tell you that new um series
that um the guys that wrote Stargate
have done the dean devil in that um the
ark
I'm actually it's gonna bomb
but if anything
when does it come out
um I think early next year isn't it and
we've seen a lot I've already seen a few
Clips since sci-fi in America
um
but if they call that Stargate The Arc
we'd all watch it
yeah you know and you know the number of
points like I could they shouldn't do it
but I can understand why they do I can
understand why Hollywood makes so many
reboots and remakes and sequels
because you're cutting out the middle
this is easy yeah easy
you know
it's just a content creator thing in it
when you create something that is
successful you want to try and do it
again you want to capture that lightning
in a bottle again but often you can't
that's that's why like IP rules I guess
all of Hollywood now you don't want to
just have like one great movie is is not
enough it needs to have a TV series a
comic book uh a sequel maybe a prequel
and and just I guess a little something
for everybody but
and then you know it's subjective give
us something good that's all I'm
concerned about
next year supposedly
Airwolf reboot
they've gone pre-production it's serious
looking at at the moment next year
don't know how it's gonna work yeah I'm
Soldier
with Kurt Russell it's in the Google
I'm gonna say if I'm wrong with that but
I think it's gonna give us more real
records for a modern movie
oh and where the lead actor says the
least amount of words
he literally says I'm back four words in
the entire film it's honestly it's
brilliant it's just he plays a soldier
that's like they're genetically
engineered soldiers
and but he's getting old and like the
next Batcher coming through and so he's
sort of like getting pushed to the side
and these youngsters are coming through
um and then he he decides to like he
goes against his program and tries to
protect this Village they're going to
attack an arc it's a great movie
definitely go watch it and that's a
that's a really good is it actually a
Blade Runner prequel
not as far as I'm aware but um
maybe I don't know I think it was
written by the same guy wasn't it Bob
wasn't it based on the um didn't he
write the story
uh the last star fighter is also
supposedly next year
um I'm trying to decipher Panther
Pickle's comment
s
raw likes boys
what
he does like boys and I think all the
little all the little kids that are
running around him
oh yeah I suppose
Egyptian in it and that's what the
Egyptians did but it is creepy if you
look back in it if you look back at it
with Suspicious Minds it's a bit creepy
um I'll tell you another thing that you
guys are probably too old for this but
there's a rumor at the moment that
Disney want to remake and Flight of the
Navigator
and please do not touch it they can't
touch that please
no it's perfect it will always be
perfect
another of just another another remake
and then I'm really pissed off about as
well but the the Flight of the Navigator
the special effects are great it's an
early 80s movies the special effects are
perfect
um there's nothing wrong you watch that
film now and it's just like if they
re-release at the cinemas now you
wouldn't you wouldn't go oh that's dated
it stuck
it's puppets and everything
practical and physical mostly so it's
it's tangible and it just it's so good I
I genuinely don't know how they did
because the the spaceship this is a film
you've not seen isn't it Matt yeah
hood film right there go watch play the
navigate honestly I think it's on
Netflix at the moment go watch it's
great the spaceship though is
um it's silver and it's shiny and it
looks like um like a a a shell or
something
um but when it's flying you can see the
reflections on infinite and this is
really early CGI it is brilliantly done
they they deserved an Oscar for the
special effects just it's a master of
keeping it simple
um special effects are really simple
it's just absolutely beautifully done
but you know another film they're
talking about doing
um oh they are definitely making a
rebake of Big Trouble in Little China
um again with Kurt Russell doesn't need
a sequel maybe but apparently it's a
hard reboot and I'm just like
just leave it alone it's brilliant
um another film Matt hasn't seen I can
tell go watch picture of little China
it's Kurt Russell right and I still
occasionally will say
um a brave man
um is afraid a brave man isn't afraid of
the weather but a wise man knows when to
get out of the rain and that was a line
from and big trouble now in China it's
it's a brilliant movie honestly so this
is your homework Matt flight the
Navigator Big Trouble in Little China I
haven't got time for people watching the
only thing I've been watching
recently is manifest
s speak about manifesting you and I've
then you need to operate something I've
not watched there so
um I do want to speak about manifest
because it is it is good
have you seen it Harris
I can't take it seriously but I haven't
I have not it's yeah don't take it the
first couple of seasons were really good
I really really enjoyed them because for
anyone who doesn't know manifest is
about a plane that disappears basically
it's the Malaysian Airlines flight just
in television it just disappears but
then they come back five years later
this is where the science fiction bit
comes in they come back and then they've
all got like they haven't all got powers
but some of them do
they haven't aged they get like
premonitions of what's going to happen
and it's it's cool
but it has kind of kind of lost its
weight but it got canceled the third
season it lost its way a lot but then it
and then it got canceled but they left
on a massive Cliffhanger which is why I
wanted to watch it again it's just been
picked up by Netflix so we've got 10
episodes
on there
uh and next year there's gonna be
another 20 drop
but a thing
with it
I thought it was going to be more of a
science fictiony kind of television show
it got a bit religious scene in it but
it got very religious talking about like
Noah's Ark and like all the animals like
rhinoceroses and things like that so
well done
just your thing he's fallen today was to
squeeze rhinoceroses into a sentence and
it still makes sense
well done well done I tip my hat team
um but yeah it did it did it got very
biblical um but it's still good um this
current season I would recommend it just
don't just you know it's a little bit
predictable
okay and the thing I liked about the
Manifest I think I really liked was that
you know if like when they disappear for
that long the the early mids first
season the guy that drowned but then he
disappeared and he was only gone for
like a month or something but then
three days once you've come back for
three days he drowned he was in the
middle of a um apocal he just drowns the
Water started pouring out of his face
anything and he drowned in the middle of
dry land something I thought that was
clever I did think
but that's the whole point of the why
why I want to see the end of it because
the the idea is they're trying to
survive the death date because they were
gone for five years so five years from
when they returned is like June 2024 or
something like that and that's when
they're all going to die unless they
solve the callings and somehow
avoid it because there's one character
called Zeke who did manage to survive I
was just gonna ask to seek survive I
don't know are they do you not see that
oh it was so good
when I stopped watching it his fingers
just started to drop off and stuff when
I stopped watching them yeah because he
he originally died in a cave and just
froze to death he does he does like
follow the callings and eventually he he
manages to overcome it and he survives
so they know it's possible and that's
the direction they're heading in yay
with powers
but showing up again later
kind of yeah instead of being on a
desert island they are they've just they
just tone and everything so this is lost
and Pushing Daisies put together
yeah yeah actually that's not far off
the Pushing Daisies are great I haven't
watched it all the way through which is
so short so I should finish it but I
don't want to just because it's it's
great Lee Pace
yeah if you haven't subscribed to the
side's Channel please do
um
really trying to get that that channel
going and there's um I'm really
struggling nobody wants to watch it
please watch it it's great I mean it's
been I'm starting to do Mystery videos
on a Friday so Friday is Mystery Machine
and I've put the first video up and I'm
going to talk about the blackie because
it's just the weirdest on the planet
um and then I've already done the second
one where I'm going to be talking about
quantum entanglement because that's the
weirdest crap as well so witchcraft it's
evil damn it
um and uh and but then I'm going to talk
about Mysteries but you know so that's
just a fun little thing to do
just because I want it I'll be watching
I love that stuff I'll be there we'll do
some live videos as well at some point
and um if you want to talk about
anything really crazy but I'm going to I
did a cons I had a channel before and it
got very conspiracies and I got yelled
at by a lot of very angry people
particularly when I said well this
doesn't make sense and I would argue
that because when people have their
theories or they stick to them
um and and other people got varying so I
want this to be a little bit more
light-hearted
talk about mistress and talk about stuff
but I don't want nobody I don't want any
death threats because I got something I
don't want and I don't want to be called
a shill as much so but yes I got more
than one person
yeah I mean Amazon pay you a pretty
penny like you know there's no no shame
in that
I said to you before
and I get I do get accused of being a
shield by Amazon when I say when I
refuse to say that Lord of the Rings was
terrible I got called to feel I I would
say anything Amazon wanted if they just
gave me my Amazon subscription for free
I'm really cheap
and you know Amazon 100K a month
100K a month I would I make I would do
anything for 100 a month Honestly though
honestly four people for that money
um
exactly so
um
but but yeah I'd say I'm I'm not but I
would I would be really cheap to buy if
they wanted to buy me and maybe when the
channel gets around 50 000ks all of a
sudden I'll be like Amazon have done it
again with another great show
that's unusual
just send SGC over
um yeah exactly it's just whatever you
want I just got my free I just got free
Prime for the rest of my life
I wish I could do that I've got too many
morals I just say what I think all the
time and I really need to stop
um I just in there
I I need my chakras realigned my mom
tried to do that once she's a hippie I
didn't I didn't like it
right so
it sounds painful
she put these crystals on the back of my
head I'm just a line in your chakras I'm
sod off woman
see I'll just give you a mushrooms and
tell you tell you to meditate for a
couple hours or something that'll do you
right yeah yeah so you're gonna try to
do Reiki it's because I'm just gonna
like
to go by your feet and I'll be able to
tell what's wrong with you
how much training did this require oh
about eight eight hours [ __ ] off oh
anyway why can't Amazon bring grab right
for the first season of Stargate see how
it goes 10 or 12 episodes if it doesn't
work change it like Walking Dead with
Fred Durabond hasn't hurt that program
ah I don't know about that Frank
derebonne he's he's great but the second
he left the Walking Dead it changed
dramatically and it didn't it petered
out quickly after that not truly but in
quality yeah
well I mean the count of like 12 Seasons
didn't it
yeah but those first two are they're
they there's nothing like them
everything else is just never like
zombies I tried to watch Walking Dead
when I was like on zombies I'm just
stupid looks walking slowly towards me
and I've got a rifle you ain't near me
Midway through season eight I was like
I'm out I'm done I watched it since
episode one since day one and Midway
through season eight they pissed me off
enough I was like I'm done and I have
not watched an episode since but
um
yeah oh story loves it
um no storm again this week because he's
still building spaceships but hopefully
he'll be back with us next week fingers
crossed
um so I they could bring I was talking
to Matt about this just before we came
on actually we're waiting or Amazon as
trying to get a production company that
seems to be I've just put a video on
actually talking about how Bad Robot
have had did actually pitch to MGM back
in September
um for Stargate that doesn't necessarily
mean Bad Robot again it but I'm aware
that they pitched for them
that might be made aware and I think
other companies have as well that that
would like to produce Stargate so the
first job seems to be
get a production company but then I was
saying to Matt before why then couldn't
a production company then approach Brad
we know Brad they don't want Brad's
script we know that if they wanted Brad
script
they would be talking to Brad they're
not
they don't want it
um
but any production company can hire who
they want can't they
should be able to all right unless it's
written in the contract otherwise yeah
which wouldn't which seems unusual
because I mean Amazon actually do other
projects with Brad He's written other
things for them that they've
um big things since since he wrote the
the the Stargate thing he wrote um a
movie for them I don't think it's been
picked up but he wrote he wrote
something else for them so they
obviously
like him as a writer and a Creator and
and they're desperate to make the fans
happy
so again even if they just come on like
come on as a creative consultant
yeah and you've just let them let them
executive produce and [ __ ] it a little
bit like we've talked about he doesn't
actually have to
Show run or even write things but if he
just gets the general ideas kind of
directed in the right way
I'm not too shabby he doesn't actually
have to show run but be an executive
producer not even the head executive
producer even
get his name on there so that the fans
don't go absolutely crazy that's what I
would do yeah yeah all day so I think I
think he should come on as a consultant
so like whoever it is that comes in
should at least speak to him and be like
give us some guidance kind of thing like
this is like the whoever comes in if
they haven't done it before there's
going to be a time where they're not
going to know sorry about the Canon they
can do all the research they're like and
watch every episode but even as like
hardcore fans it's things that we forget
so
asking the Creator
is this like
uh is this
in line with Canon I guess
Joseph malozi on gate world doing
interviews and that he'll get questions
after I send a couple of live ones you
know get questions and he's like going I
can't remember I'm gonna have to check
and like I mean even the Creator didn't
you know couldn't remember it all
um it's you know it's important I've
seen that and the the what was his name
the the host he's just there reeling it
off like oh yeah you did this in episode
[Laughter]
but you'd get the feeling and you'd get
the tone right if you bought the Creator
and I think that's the main thing and
somebody else can be there going through
and checking all the bloody you know and
that's why they're creating this Bible
and everything for whatever production
company it's like I said in the video I
did today the production company will
come in they will be licensed to create
this target series but they will get
this as part of the contractual
obligation this is what we want you to
to base the project around this is your
Bible this is what you can and can't do
with it even though Bad Robot apparently
it went in immediately I'm like well
we're going to do tell me why are we
thinking that's irrelevant and it goes
for [ __ ] sake bad driver stop doing
timing why me things we don't like it
bad reboot stop it yeah we didn't like
you when you did it with Star Trek we
knew what you're doing don't do it again
um but what
Amazon did do a brad right continuation
and a separate unrelated reboot I'm
assuming within the Stargate Universe
could that work that's kind of what DC
you're doing with like Batman and
everyone else at the moment they've got
like separate universes cracking on and
it's
I think I think that'll just confuse
things it'll just be confusing because
everybody wants it
you'd have some people watching the main
show some people watching the the
spin-off show and there'll be two
separate entities and it would just be
confusing and then no one will know
where they are
I think it would it just leads to a
divisive fan base because some people
are like well this is the real Stargate
no no no this is the real Stargate
I think it kind of work for the Batman
series because you've got it's going to
be a cartoon and then two live-action
series isn't it one Batman Beyond and
then the regular Batman Batman Beyond
descent in the future so
that could work because it's what we've
got in the future Batman yeah and then
an Affleck's coming back as Batman
so there same time period different
universes
yeah I don't agree with that yeah I
don't agree with that happening I don't
think it should be out for long I was
talking to somebody before this this
came on actually because he's talked to
me about the Batman thing and I was
saying I I there's 100 going to be a
sequel to the Batman with Robert
Pattinson but I think I don't when they
decided to do that though Ben Affleck
wasn't coming back now Ben Affleck has
agreed to come back and David saslap has
gone as a new CEO and it really wants to
push that he wants to keep all the best
bits of the DC EU and forget all the
crap bits
um so Ben Affleck's gonna looks like
he's going to come back so you're going
to have two competing Batmans
you're gonna have the Robert plants in
Batman and whatever Ben Affleck does
that can't work and Michael Keaton right
and Michael Keaton is well he's in the
CW at the moment he stopped but I I'm
100 on with you
right yeah but Keaton is returning and
his flash has an alternate version of
Batman yeah
but it's a Multiverse Batman isn't it so
that's how they get around there but I'm
with you though if they do the Batman
Beyond if you need a geriatric Batman
it's got to be Michael Keaton please all
day if they don't do that
absolute thoughts
um
and obviously we have we have the sad
loss of the voice of Batman
um Kevin Connery
Kevin Conroy
um which is
it's just so good he could have been a
good geriatric like live-action Batman
just because he was kind of always a
scrawny or kind of skinny kind of guy
maybe not scrawny's not the type of word
but he was a thin kind of guy that would
have looked good as like an older
geriatric Batman
but I think you guys are Too Young Too
Young to realize though what an impact
Batman the Animated Series had
before that I'll tell you what you can
do is is to try to get into the familiar
frame of this watch an original episode
of He-Man right which is really cheesy I
mean I loved it when I was a kid I watch
it now and I'm like oh my God I've seen
here man
um as an adult and that it was not good
no it was oh it's poorly made what they
would do is they would just have a
picture and just the mouth moved and
things like just save money
um you know it was like and then Batman
the Animated Series come out and it was
so much better than everything else it
was I mean we used to I used to sit down
on a Saturday morning and sit and just
wait for it to come on and you know just
like it it it was just Beyond it was it
was so good and his voice was one of the
reasons why you know it's just
absolutely phenomenal series
um
he'll be missed
and when the next couple of animated the
bad robe are actually actually doing a
bad Batman animated series of Warner
Brothers he was supposed to do the voice
so
um
yeah yeah oh he's only uh was he 66 or
something yeah yeah
um
the powers that can be can pass and Brad
rice script I wouldn't like it or
whether you're still full of great ideas
and that's what we're saying isn't it
just because
I mean anything the world's completely
different now to three years ago when he
wrote that script as well so I don't
think Brad Wright would even be bothered
I'm absolutely you'll just go yeah it's
a different world now let's let's do
something new I don't think he he'd care
in the slightest and we know he wouldn't
he's been on Twitter saying I would love
to have been involved I got a load of
people I've basically did a video last
week saying it's confirmed he's
confirmed that he's not involved and
I've still had a load of people going
you're a liar
and um and nothing to go at me I'm just
like literally on Twitter that's not
what he said that's not what he said
guys come on you don't have to read
between the lines much here he says it
would have been fun at the end that's
how he ends it I mean come on uh but
they're I've got I've got a couple of
trolls that really don't like me
regardless of what I say
so but anyway guys
it's been emotional we're past an hour
my voice hurts oh
we've sorted the world out once again
hello as always yeah what have we
learned today there are rhinoceroses in
the morning Fest if you want to go watch
that there are actually no rhinoceroses
I just had to say rhinoceros is at some
point during this live stream and it
worked did they even mention we gave it
away quickly Noah's Ark is involved
that's what that's what that's what I
was saying I know how I'm gonna link it
genius
um we've probably destroyed black
panthers chances because No One's Gonna
Go watch it now obviously the the good
thing about Black Panther this weekend
though it did make as of this morning on
Sunday morning it's 330 million dollars
so
if that's that's the biggest of the year
so far really I think opening weekend
wise it's gonna hit a billion it's just
whether it can make as much as Top Gun
but um yeah it might not be a Million
Miles Away
so my next thought real quick though is
if this gets to 300 million where are we
going to see Avatar 2 at
because that I think is gonna I think
that's gonna blow this out the water
because after everybody was saying okay
so it's black panther or Avatar 2 is
going to be that Top Gun kind of rival
for the year I don't think it's gonna be
black panther I really don't I Avatar 2
is gonna
beards real big leg to stand on yeah I
think we'd say that from them
re-releasing Avatar and it absolutely
destroyed everybody in the
thing so I went inside it it was great
I'm not excited about Avatar at all and
to me it looks like exactly what a movie
Just wetter
really
you're watching the extended advert and
it's them
um and they're like oh isn't it nature
and or isn't it lovely and then there's
a load of the the we turn up in machines
and start trying to kill everybody
that's the first film
um all I'm just saying yeah
it looks like the first movie again
but wetter
but I think I think it's a different
type of film it looks like a family film
to me because you know you remember how
Sigourney Weaver's coming back right
uh she's like one of the kids or
something
which is so hard like awesome actually
she looks really good I think it's gonna
be interesting I don't know I can never
bet against James Cameron ever no if if
anything you can do that I don't think I
can name a Bob James Cameron movie
I can't he did a vampires movie years
ago that was just my favorite vampire
movie
um but yeah we should do a video on that
just go through James Cameron's movies
because he's just it's just brilliant
film after brilliant film
that's not a bad idea go go through
different like directors best sci-fi
films or something like that yeah
sci-fi's aren't they so I'll tell you
what we'll do a James Cameron one in a
couple of weeks
at Genesis and that was pretty crap
he did what sir Terminator Genesis
did he actually do terminate Genesis
though well he didn't direct it he just
produced it he just gave him some cash
and some pointers
right I can see where they were going
with that but it was pretty crappy and
even the greatest of anything is going
to do the odd the odd sideways chicken
and I was like
well he he produced uh the new one
Terminator dark fate too I still haven't
seen it but I just know it didn't get
the best of reviews it's not very good
either yeah that's good that was Tim
Miller of Deadpool I guess they got the
um casting wrong with that
dark fate is that the one where you've
got the really old
yeah
um Linda Hamilton comes back the woman's
name Linda Hamilton yeah yeah yeah but
she's
um the queen isn't she oh I've forgotten
her real name
um she's the chick from Game of Thrones
anyway but that's that's why they got it
wrong that was that's a different one
that's different that's okay
10 years ago is
Mackenzie Davis I think is her name the
actress yes another proper um the proper
um Corner came back didn't she and of
course she did
um but but yeah that's there's too many
two minute moves yeah they should have
stopped with the the Sarah Sarah Connor
Chronicles that was kind of the entire
Corner Chronicles I love that Series
yeah it's great and the bloke from
Beverly Hills 902 and I was actually
really good in it as well
he was great I've never seen him
anything since
I can't think of anything you know hello
it's great
um
yeah
um Bob agrees with us I think it's great
it's so such a shame it got canceled
it's just it's just getting really good
as well
yeah and the the evil terminate was
fantastic and
um God
I can't stay awake that long oh I'm
gonna bring a couple joints with me life
is gonna be good and and I am excited
can't do that in the cinema but unless
you're going to completely different
Cinemas to me
I step outside real quick it's
California if if you'd like to put
joints in the cinema and I'm not sitting
with my kids someone's getting punched
oh we the other day
um
it wasn't Black Panther
what
I gotta remember
Lou what movie were we at where somebody
smoked a blunt while we were sitting in
the theater
because this is somebody literally lit
up a blunt in the middle of the movie
theater the other day I was like can I
have some but just too far away I
couldn't go ask but it was the guy that
answered the phone and we all nearly
killed him yeah but he answered the
photo hello like normal volume he did
like ah oh God I'm just gonna go outside
he went yeah what hey what
no no
because if if you don't hang up the
phone right now we're going to kill you
and it's
anyway guys it's been emotional I want
to go I want to go and eat man united
are drawing one all I know you're all
desperate to know the score I'm really
really angry
I think it's about to end
it I quite like my team but the guy
don't pissed me off at the moment
um I need to get into some other game
that's um like snooker
um I play snooker by the way I just
don't watch it Snickers always good to
watch
there's lots of drama that's great
what what what are y'all saying okay
is that snorkeling scuba what is tanuka
[Applause]
big you know the game you know the game
pool it's his big brother
yeah right right playing pool Billiards
Pool yes
um eight nine ball whatever
um there's the British play it properly
so you know like how everything the
Americans do is how fast and lazy
um
and we do it properly so the table is
just too big so you can't actually reach
the balls half the time
um and the pockets are basically the
same size as the damn ball so it's
really hard to get them in
and then the system is also really
complicated because
every ball basically has a different
points you've got 10 Reds which are
worth one and then you've got a yellow
yellow green brown blue pink and black
and they're worth two three four five
six seven
um the fouling system is insanely
complicated
so yes we play a game we play it
properly
you guys
make it really difficult because there's
nothing better to do on that island
huh
no man which we're Geniuses okay I I had
to come back with equipment something
yeah but how long's a pool game take 15
minutes
you can't get a lot of drinking though
you're playing someone well
oh a snooker game can last hours
I'm drinking the whole time so for me
and also the other thing is I'm married
so I can go out and say I'm gonna go
play a game of snooker have three pints
and I've literally not lied because I've
only actually played one game because it
takes so long to finish the tab game
particularly once you've had a couple
but I'm actually the member of a men
only Club where they have snooker tables
beautiful snooker tables and there are
no women allowed they don't even have
women cleaners
um do you hear this anti-wokenness
coming from Jay oh yes
um I absolutely adore it but to be fair
there's a woman's group like next door
there's a Women's Club that men aren't
allowed in and they're literally like
next door to each other
so you'll have like quarterly dances
right and you'll just fight on Billiards
no we they are not allowed in the
building they meet in the alleyway is
like a 1960s gangster going good
[Laughter]
story comes around the corner yeah well
ours is actually called a literally a
literary Institute so we're supposed to
go and read but really there's a big TV
with sports on and like four snooker
tables
so and then hitting club next door and I
imagine it's just a massive gin bar
because I tell you what those women come
out there destroyed they they have a
lovely evening and they're not knitting
no it could be knitting and drinking you
never know actually get a pint of lager
in the in the club for two quid
which is like two dollars I'm coming
down to where you live
shoot I am allowed to take visitors but
guys come on we have to go now I'm
genuinely I've got to go eat so it has
been really really good as always thank
you so much thank you everybody in the
comments you've really helped us along
today and come up with some um brilliant
things for us to talk about
um say bye man adiosio
foreign
guys thank you so much we will see you
next week as always and you this is me
trying to delay while I'm trying to find
the outro button but I found it bye guys
[Music]
thank you